These kernels look similar.
Both of them are reading 5 values for memory,
performing the same arithmetic operations, and writing a single value to memory.
And you'll get good coalescing in both cases.
But the second kernel has a great deal of reuse.
Two adjacent threads will be reading 4 of the same 5 values.
So tiling the n array by copying it into shared memory
before performing the averaging operation will capture that reuse and make the code run faster.
In the first kernel, each value from the A, B, C, D and E arrays gets used only once.
So tiling will just add an extra step without allowing any reuse.
So the second code snippet will benefit from tiling and the first won't.
In fact, the first will probably slow down.